[Musique]
de toute ma carrière je n'avais encore
jamais vu un pilote faire preuve d'un
talent à spa et d'un tel talent mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça surgie de
nulle part à l'obscur a connu tient tête
à la gagne il remonte le peloton est
apparemment le braqueur boissons et
rebonjour les aficionados nous sommes en
compagnie de la nouvelle star dit la
gagne alors oui qu'est-ce qui vous a
donné envie de devenir pilote ou là je
vais vous dire d'elle
tout le monde a une activité dans la vie
qui le rend particulièrement heureux
mais pour moi ça a toujours été de
rouler à tombeau ouvert
oui le beau blond là bas est ce que tu
veux bien dormir s'il te plaît dormir il
faut des heures pour décompresser après
le cospar et alors que quand vous avez
fait vos débuts dans l'indy lights est
ce que vous vous imaginiez vous
retrouver ici aujourd'hui je vous dirai
ce que me disait toujours mon père quand
j'étais petit aucun rêve n'est trop
grand et aucun rêveur n'est trop petit